speaking of satirical trolls we have a
voicemail number that number is two one
nine two David P I am going to play a
voicemail for you today it is very short
it's only 15 seconds long this is either
one of our most uninformed callers ever
or an absolutely genius
satirical voice actor this I think is
related to recent conversations about
how educated versus uneducated white
voters vote in American elections take a
listen to this you be the judge
most ignorant caller ever or brilliant
satirical voice actor so how do you
weasel handed a little sucker just
because that's why people ain't educated
like you dumb suckers you think you're
educated this is racial discrimination
maybe we ought to send you back to
Poland thank you so I would think it's
real accept send me back to Poland I
don't know where that came from so I
don't know you tell me let me know
either by replying if you're watching on
youtube or shoot me a tweet at de Pakman
was that real or was that satire on
today's bonus show ex Massachusetts
governor Deval Patrick is reportedly
exploring a late entry into the 2020
Democratic primary now you will remember
some of you will remember that deval
Patrick has been a good friend to the
David Pakman show I've interviewed him a
couple of times despite the fact that he
would always call me mark uh not David
that's okay a busy guy he has been
pretty good in terms of making himself
available to the David Pakman show when
he was governor and he is an interesting
potential entrant with some pretty
status quo corporatist stuff in his
background including being the lawyer
for coca-cola so we will talk about that
on today's bonus show we will talk about
Amazon launching a new grocery store as
an alternative to Whole Foods but hold
on Amazon bought Whole Foods now they're
going to compete with Whole Foods
don't worry I'll explain it all on the
bonus show and a viral video a black man
handcuffed can cuffed for eating a
sandwich at a train station officials
are now apologizing for
was a really cringey interaction on the
on the behalf of the police officer I
will mention we will discuss all of
those stories and much much more on
today's bonus show two ways to get
access to the bonus show number one
become a member go to WWE at medCom
click the red sign up button takes under
a minute you'll be in on the bonus show
second option go to patreon.com/scishow
become a patron at at least the $5 a
month level you will also get instant
access to that world-famous bonus show
hosted by me Monday through Thursday
hosted by producer Pat on Fridays last
Friday
or maybe the one before producer Pat had
a story about his pants getting stolen
how could his pants get stolen right off
of his body well maybe it didn't go down
exactly that way you can find out on the
bonus show I will speak to you then in
just a few short moments